my thoughts at the end of day 36 America
and shutdown now when we started to turn
the corner on this virus we knew we
would see a constant effort to blunt any
good news so media figures politicians
and even some government officials seem
far too comfortable in shutdown mode if
you can believe it now Nancy Pelosi
lives in a multimillion-dollar mansion
in the Pacific Heights neighborhood of
San Francisco it's very nice and then
some weekends at her vineyard in Napa
Valley so do you really think Nancy
mines doing her press interviews from I
don't know her gourmet kitchen you could
Pelosi what have you found what are you
gonna share with us from your home
chocolate really what chocolate
chocolate candy oh wow now while
choosing between the lemon peach gelato
and the coconut sorbet she lets small
businesses desperate for relief dangling
she used their pain to extract
concessions that were basically totally
unrelated to helping small businesses in
that PPP extension bill that the
president plans on signing now of course
she's not alone many have played the
moment for maximum political leverage
and shameless self-promotion but
seriously while there's no minimizing
the horrible human tragedy of this virus
it's a lot of people a lot of suffering
there is good news out there the
infection rate is declining in most
places around the world including in New
York and although more than 44,000
Americans have lost their lives to cope
at 19 we have 330 million more Americans
who still need to protect and reclaim
theirs doing this requires a frank
assessment of how we got here we were
told first that we had to shut
everything down in order to save the
health care system well today the only
thing being threatening the health care
system is the shutdown itself
number two we were told that we had to
lock down because we didn't have enough
ventilators now we have more than enough
ventilators
number three now some governor's say
that they can't reopen because they
don't have enough tests
well how many well some experts say we
need to do 20 million tests a day
oh that's realistic we're doing roughly
120,000 tests a day right now more than
any country on Earth and number 4
even if governor's secure the tests
they're gonna claim that they can't
reopen until they have an army of
tracers and trackers well how many do
they need one estimate says they need
300,000 well how long would that take to
set up maybe I don't know I can't think
about how long would that take to train
all those people our state governor's
prepared to pay for it all
and why should Montana have to pay the
bill for build the bloviator mistakes
number 5 of course even if we have
enough tests and workers to do the
contact tracing we'll be told that we
have to stay lockdown until there's a
vaccine well either dr. Fauci has to
concede that we may never have a vaccine
for this coronavirus it's gonna take a
long time if we have one SAR is
eventually burned out before we tested
the one from mice to humans we don't
have a vaccine for HIV but thankfully
wonderful therapies were developed to
save lots of lives the left doesn't have
any intention of letting society return
to normal they never liked the old
normal remember Trump was elected during
the old normal days brick Cavanaugh was
confirmed at the Supreme Court during
the old normal and the Russia hoax
collapsed during the normal days now
those who've been frustrated that
America hasn't evolved fast enough to
progress events are using this crisis to
change society they hope as Andrew Cuomo
said to remake it and to reimagine it
and right now to frank assessment
they're winning millions are out of work
and dependent on a government rescue
doctor pouchy is focusing only on the
virus not of course on the broader
American life that must go on before the
nation itself flatlines
what does the president need to do now
number one push back against any efforts
to move the goal posts we've saved the
health care system in New York no one is
running short of ventilators those were
the reasons that we shut down and they
no longer apply
number two control the narrative on
testing and tracking keep explaining to
the press to the governor's and members
of Congress that the US government has
made testing and tracking progress and
they're gonna continue to emphasize two
key points our efforts have been
world-class and current testing and
tracking efforts are sufficient to allow
significant portions of the country to
reopen plus they got 25 billion today
for testing and tracking the states did
in the New Deal number three make deals
with blue state governors and mayor's
the president has demonstrated time and
again this has been a great aspect of
his leadership during this period that
he's willing to work with anyone and
everyone to get America back to work
keep it up some might act in bad faith
out there we know that but others just
want their people to get back to work
and their kids back to school
number four keep working with Congress
even when members seem unreasonable and
pretty mean-spirited take the
temperature down it's good for everybody
we passed a series of these short-term
measures that are designed to get money
in people's pockets and get folks
through this immediate crisis now we're
going to need legislation that will help
restart and rebuild the country as the
president said we would look forward to
phase 4 would be infrastructure the
president's been talking about
infrastructure since the campaign roads
bridges broadband especially broadband
now to rural America is is very
important we've talked about incentives
for restaurants sports entertainment
because these businesses have been
impacted the president has talked
multiple times about a payroll tax cut
in five America first now more than ever
the president was a hundred percent
correct to use his executive authority
to freeze immigration during this crisis
it would be wrong
and unjust for Americans laid off by the
virus to be replaced with new immigrant
labor flown in from abroad is we want to
protect our US workers and I think as we
move forward we will become more and
more protective of them a short break
from new immigration depending on the
time we're talking about will protect
the solvency of our health care system
and provide relief to jobless Americans
now it would have been even more America
first and effective let alone more
popular if he had extended this pause to
the thousands and thousands of temporary
workers that come in every year but this
is an important and will be a very
popular start so our America is going to
agree with Trump of course they are
nearly eight and ten support a pause
according to the latest USA Today if
so's poll of course the usual suspects
were enraged by this move they wanted
unlimited immigration even during a
pandemic that's not where the problem is
coming from and it avoids him having to
deal with the fact that we went for
almost two months or more without action
can only be understood as a political
matter not as a public health matter the
redirecting some blame to foreigners who
presumably have something to do with
this a president is trying to fan the
flames of xenophobia Americans brought
coronavirus here it was already here I'd
like laughable they accused Trump of
xenophobia when he shut down travel from
China they're still doing it
so Trump has smoked them out here
brilliantly they're perfectly happy
locking down the American people while
throwing the doors open to thousands of
people from every country on earth so
shame a millennial in the grocery store
for not wearing a mask but welcomed a
symptomatic foreign spreaders and pick
up the tab health care it's on us the
American taxpayer that's how radical
these people are on the issue of
immigration they won't even let us go to
church if we're sitting six feet apart
but they want immigration flowing like
there was never a crisis so until the
pro lockdown folks are willing to
support
it's to reopen the economy they're in no
position to insist that immigration
should continue as normal that's absurd
the president is showing that us through
this crisis how America first goes from
being a campaign theme to a way of life
and those are my thoughts at the end of
day 36 America in shutdown